how's Gilmer as - I found this amazing
title this morning cold alien makeout
simulator and I don't know baby bus but
I'm pretty [ __ ] excited about this
game I hope my girlfriend isn't watching
oh hey there baby are you doing be
careful right
do you camera laughter why don't I I
don't know why
uh-uh oh god this is disgusting does
anyone else want this one I am not
merely enough drunk for this alright you
know what I love doing this for my bros
but only for my bros all right come in
oh god oh god this is so nasty this is
so weird
they did not invent virtual reality for
this I just know it alright can we do
some motorboating please oh that one
oh god I am giving an alien a [ __ ]
our guy let's just be friends
Oh what's my bj not good enough for you
I just did the gayest [ __ ] in my entire
history of appearance
oh that was my favorite your [ __ ]
flight she just used me for my body I
feel violated
Oh a little a little a little a little